All right. Good morning.
Thank you all for coming.
My name is Bradley Horowitz.
I'm vice president of photos and sharing
here at Google and it's my pleasure to
welcome lovee a gie with us this morning.
You all know love it.
Yeah,
I'm going to do this
super brief introduction because I
actually want her to tell her story. Um,
you all know lovey.
I have to confess a week ago I didn't,
but a good mutual friend Lisa Stone and
invited me to host this talk and so I
went into a crash course on
learning about lovey and uh,
why she is so prominent
in the blogging space.
And so I've spent that last week getting
to know her work and I'm super excited
and as I shared in the invite,
somewhat nervous to be up here
cause she tells it like it is and
it's pretty clear I'm part of the problem
that
lovey please.
Let's welcome,
that's hilarious.
Ah,
well thank you.
Thank you for coming.
I know you're bouncing around the whole
country and we're glad you had a chance
to stop at Google. Had to do it.
Have you ever been here before?
No,
this is my first time on Google's campus.
Well, I hope you get a chance
to meet people and look around.
I heard about the epic
slides you guys have.
We, we have slides. We have
a weird bikes. We have food,
you know, we'll, we'll treat you right.
It's going to have fun. Okay. Um,
so I want to start, I think most people
here know it, but for posterity and, uh,
for the, the videotape, um, tell
us your story. I mean, who are you,
how did you get to this chair?
By being a professional, a trouble maker.
And that's how I got to this chair. Um,
I'm a writer. I'm a speaker. I'm a techie
and I have been blogging for 13 years.
I started blogging in 2003.
I was in college and I was peer pressured
into doing it because my friends were
like, you should start a web
blog. And I was like, okay.
So I went to zango.com and start a web.
And I started a long ago
that Sangha Sangha, okay.
Remember Sangha like next to
Friendster and everything. Right.
And I started blogging.
I was talking about college life and all
my randomness and Shenanigans and, uh,
who I was beefing with that day.
Nothing interesting.
And I kept basically I have my
college career, chronic board,
which for good in our bed, I just, I read
it and I was like, this is awful. Um,
when I graduated from college,
I deleted that blog and I was like,
I'm going to start something new.
And I go to blog spot,
fire up this new blog called
the lovies random rants.
And I was talking about all
things, pop culture, television,
anything I felt like talking about,
but not myself anymore.
So that's how blogging for me started.
And uh,
it basically took on a life of its own.
And you were born in Africa,
grew up in Chicago.
Yeah. So I was born in Nigeria
and uh, when I was nine,
you guys shouting from Nigeria,
right? Nigeria. So, um,
we moved to Chicago when I was nine
and nobody told me we were moving.
I thought we were going on vacation. And
then I started school and I was like, oh,
this means we're staying. Oh. Um,
and it was a big culture shock for me
because I went from never having to be the
new girl.
Like my best friend was the niece of
the person who owned the private school.
I went to add,
been going to high school since I was two.
So walking in the room and see people
who didn't look like me and having to
reintroduce myself and basically take
on a new persona was a huge shock to my
system. But yeah, I had this accent too.
Well, no, not this accident actually.
I had a major Nigerian accent and uh,
I ended up having to,
I lost it consciously by
mimicking my classmates. Right.
And like trying to repeat what they
were saying and how they were saying it.
And then by high school my
accident was mostly gone.
Right. Yeah. She thinks it's gone anyway.
Right. You're like, I'm, no, I hear
it. I just said we're Nigerian. Yeah.
So do you think that experience of sort
of being a transplant at nine years old
and uh, being different, um,
informs some of who you are and,
and your ability to sort of stand
outside of things and you know,
tell it like it is, is that,
is that part of why you, you
well yeah.
So the tell it like it is in this,
that is me is my Nigerian
is and its true essence.
Like Nigerians were not a
great filter and people,
okay we're not the ones who were like,
Oh let me like make sure I coded in
all types of Nice things. We just say,
well we did, we feel like if you
come to like my family dinner,
we spent the whole time
laughing at each other.
Like somebody would walk in wearing a
sweater that's not cute. It's about,
and somebody will always be like,
why do you have that online?
It's just how we function.
And I'm in my writing.
My writing is essentially
who I am in real life in,
in Prince and because I want people who
know me to read my work and be like,
okay, I actually hear her
voice. That's exactly her.
So how I write very much
translates to who I am.
That's interesting.
And uh,
in your youth from like nine through high
school and things like that, did you,
were you extroverted class clown?
Like do you feel like, you know,
before in the pre blogging, pre college
years, like what was that like for you?
I have been the class clown forever.
Um,
this person that you see is who
I was in high school. Like my,
I still have the same friends that did
in high school and we were just a goofy
group of people will be in the hallway
just acting the fool or you know,
I'm playing spades in the lunchroom
and just spend all time laughing and
basically my group of friends are a
really good reflection who I am. Like,
you think I'm funny?
You come to Brunch with us and you'll
be in tears because none of them have
behavior or sense.
So it's just how I've been and being able
to have it translate to my writing has
been great because literally I,
um,
have these friends who've known me
for 20 years and people were like, oh,
how did you find your voice? And I was
like, do you see them? That's me. Hmm.
So it's not even a matter of
me having to find my voice. Um,
it's me just grown it up.
Yeah.
So you went to University of Illinois?
Yes.
And I love how she drops like 13 years.
Like that's a long time in tech
and stuff like that. But you know,
way before you got there, uh, the
web browser was invented there.
Internet explorer. Yes. Yeah. Most
of them were very proud of that.
Knowing. Yeah. My wife went
to school there too. Oh yeah.
It's, it's one of the things they tell
you, what are you going to orientation?
And they were like, at Illinois we
invented, I was like, impressive.
I will come here.
Yes.
Cool. This has changed everything
for me. I must be here. Yes.
And did you got into blogging
Wallet College and so yeah,
like do you think that's
how you had access?
Like how did you even come to do that?
Um, so I, I've always
liked just computers.
I took my computer type classes in school.
I was the person who actually
took an excel class for fun. Um,
so for me, I've always kind of
seen the value of computers and um,
all of these types of software.
But I was also the person who started
infusing social media into the work that I
was doing. Like I've been an early
adopter of most platforms and I'm,
blogging was just another thing that
I was kind of an early adopter. I,
because when I started blogging it was
just playing on the Internet. Um, so,
but I was doing it because
I thought it was fine. Um,
how I've been approaching technology
since I had to go to the library to go to,
to get my email. My first email
account was a hotmail account
and I think it was like
vet bet at hotmail,
but then when we had AOL and you know,
so I've been through,
I've seen the evolution of the
Internet grow and has been really cool,
but I've always found it valuable.
Hmm.
So that first phase you said you were
sort of blogging your college experience,
but then you deleted the
whole thing. Yeah. Um, do you
still have a copy or? I do.
Okay.
And so many fans and Google cache.
No, I'm just kidding. Right?
Oh yeah, no. Like I had Comic Sans
Font and everything and it was like,
it was just awful.
And it's not up online right now?
No. Okay. I think I like, I actually
was like, okay, legit deleted.
But before I deleted the blog,
I like copied and paste every single,
every single post.
It's a word document in the word document
was giant because it's three years of
me in college being a fool, being
like, oh, this is my roommate.
I didn't really like her that time.
So That's interesting because you're
so out there and so vulnerable,
honest about things.
Have you posted things that you
regret or go back and delete or edit?
Like what's it like having that out there?
Cause these days,
once you put something out
there, it's out there. Yeah.
Um, well so here's the thing
is my blogging for so long. Um,
the good and the bad thing
is it chronicles your growth
as a human being and as
a thought.
It's somebody who thinks about the world
and so things that there are things
that I wrote in 2009,
but I would never write today cause I
vehemently disagree with myself. I'm done.
I'm like, no, that was wrong. You
shouldn't. But some of those things,
I keep it up to remind myself where I
came from and who I was in that moment.
And the like, even thinking about
high school essays that I won,
I won like two major essay contest
in high school writing an essay on,
um,
whether people should receive reparations.
And my stance was, no, you didn't do that.
Why do you get reparations and I one
essay contest and I read the essay and I
was like, God, that's
terrible. No. So, but it's,
it's really good to still have the record
of who you were because you see how
you've grown, how you've changed,
how your thought has changed.
College changed everything
about my politics and,
and how I look at the world at large.
So who I was before college is completely
different from who I am now in terms
of my beliefs.
And I guess how much of what you do do
you do for yourself and how much do you
do for others? You know, it sounds like
bit of both. A little bit of both.
I try to do most of it for myself.
I think that's why you're so appealing.
Well, because my whole thing is, okay,
I'm one,
I'm not writing an echo chamber.
So the idea that I'm just
writing for myself is false,
but I am writer because if I don't
write the words kind of stay with me.
So like I'm the person who's,
who's taken a nap on the plane writing
blog posts too at the same time,
which is completely weird.
But I wake up with an entire post in my
head already and I'm just like, ah, okay,
cool.
Um,
so in that way I'm writing for myself but
also I'm writing for people to consume
it and um, hopefully change hearts and
minds cause I'm also not trying to write,
um, to preach to the choir all the time
cause it's like at that point what's the
point?
So it's a combination.
So you're an early technology
adopter. Yeah. Early on.
Blogspot early with blogging.
Um, are you keeping up?
Like where are you at on vlogging?
Snapchat, Instagram, Twitter, you know,
like is it, are there enough
hours in the day? Yes.
No, there are not enough
hours in the day and I'm,
I'm officially getting filling
like the Odi and tech because
13 years,
14 years come on veteran. But, um,
there are certain platforms I cannot get
with even though I've tried and I'm a
digital strategist and I can see the value
in them, but me personally, me, myself,
and I personally,
I have a trouble,
I'm infusing it into my daily snapchat
is one of them. I have tried you guys
snapchat.
Here's the thing that I have a problem
with generation in millennials and
generation social media,
which I'm a very firm part of is we feel
like everything we do is interesting
and it's not,
it's not like people all spend all day
on snapchat tell you exactly what they
did in every moment of their day. And I,
I'll log in to snapshot and I was black.
You know what?
Today's the day I'm going to give it a
try and I'm going to scroll through and
people are walking to the bus like,
yes, I'm walking to the bus. Dot. Okay.
And, and, and the filters are killing
me softly. You guys like the filters,
the flower filter, the
face. I'm just like,
why does everybody look like a cartoon
right now? So I have a snapchat account,
but I log into it like once a month and
I think I've snapchat at twice total.
And I do actually have on snapchat double
life because I'm in these random rooms
that I call myself Forrest Gump.
I do all of these interesting things.
That's you totally right. Like
can you believe it? But it's like,
you know what, catch me on Instagram,
catch me on Twitter. I'm on there.
Catch me on Facebook to add snapchat
towards a catch a moment by moment.
Thing of my day is just a lot.
Yeah.
And what about vlogging or youtube or
I have actively rejected
you to why I have job.
I said it had Google.
Um, I've, I've, I've made it a point
not to be on youtube because I did.
I don't like the community.
Well, this is something I wanted to talk
about because social media has tons of
upside. It is part of why you're here
today and part of why we know about you,
but it's also a place where there's a
lot of hate and a lot of misinformation.
Yep. And filter bubble. And I want to
talk about that experience. So, you know,
we're heartbroken.
You've rejected youtube wholesale.
Most of the people who aren't here today
are working on that and fixing it as we
speak. So we'd like you to give it a
try, uh, tomorrow or next week. Um,
but you know, what a, is your experience
both good and bad if you've been trolled,
have you been doxed have you been, you
know, harmed by social media personally,
and how do we,
how should we as owners of,
uh, some of the services that people
use, think about what we can do to,
without getting into censorship
and sort of, you know,
repressing people's feelings. How do we
create safe environments for, for people?
So,
okay.
So my decision to not do youtube has
been one because I hate editing stuff.
And again,
I don't want to just meet me talk.
You're lazy is the easiest
part of it. Oh, absolutely.
But then the second part is I hate the
community on there because that community
is so full of hate because at one point
it was where you can actually comment
anonymously.
Yup.
And what that spurs his keyboard courage
of people who decide that since they
are a number in a system, they can say
whatever they want as opposed to be,
it'd being attached to their name.
So a lot of my friends are youtube stars
and like people who've their following
on youtube, like Francesca Ramsey. Um,
and I used to see the comments
they would get all day,
every day and to avoid the comments they
would have to sit there and moderating
it either themselves,
which of course triggers all
types of like trauma and um,
or they just actively just be like,
I threw up a video.
I just never go back into my
comments section. And for me,
the power of the Internet is connecting
with people and I think that's really
important. So I was like, you know
what, I'm a writer. I prefer to write,
I'll be riding. Y'all catch me there.
I don't want to do videos yet. Um,
and I know youtube started
fixing some of that.
I was never really recruited
to come back into the fold. Um,
consider this an invitation, an
invitation, come back into the fall.
Like I was using my Vimeo channel
because I was like, you know what,
I need store some video somewhere.
So I just didn't feel like youtube is a
place now in terms of the hate online in
trolling.
So as a black woman,
as a woman is one as a
black person is another,
as a black woman is another.
Um,
the type of feedback that we get on
social media is completely different from
everyone else. So this was tested out
by, people aren't on Twitter actually,
where they did like a week where they
change. They exchanged uh, avatars.
So black women and white men decides to
do this experiment and exchange avatars
and see how the difference in your Avatar
affects how the responses you get are.
And the white men who had the black woman
avatars for the week were stunned by
the type of vitriol they got for
simple stuff that they were saying.
For me as, um, aside I sources
and the professional shader,
I am lucky to not receive some of
the hate that a lot of people get.
Cause here's the thing, I can
beat you at that game. Like,
I've spent all my life being
shady, I could do this. But um,
I've been fortunate with the trolls are
afraid of you is the trolls don't come
at me as much as they come in to
other people. I will say that. Um,
but one thing that I've loved about my
social media platforms is people saying
that my community was reflects me,
which is
king compliment.
Um,
on no matter where I am on the Internet,
I like to keep my spaces clear,
full of hate and free of hate and as
safe as a space that you can get in a
public domain.
So my audience is also very protective
of the spaces that I've created.
So if any type of hate creeps through,
they handle it before I even get there
because they understand that this is one
of the few places you can go
and actually read the comments.
So how everyone else tells
you never read the comments.
You want to read the comments on my post,
on my Facebook or my Twitter
on anywhere that I am,
because my audience is super smart,
super thoughtful,
and they've managed to maintain a space
that is actually good and it shows the
best of humanity as opposed
to the rest of the Internet,
which kind of shows awfulness.
So I want to talk about filter bubble.
This contract you mentioned you don't
just like to preach to the choir,
right? That's part of what you do, but
you also want to reach people and um,
change people's minds.
Um,
this morning my wife showed me a site
called friends who like trump.com.
I don't know if you've seen this,
but it actually exposes your Facebook
friends who've actually liked Trump.
So I did a bit of unfriending
this morning. I can
only, I'm proud to say out of a
thousand or so friends I had eight.
And um, you know, most of whom I
either didn't know who they were or,
uh, hadn't spoken to them in 30
years. I did grow up in Michigan,
which can have little pockets of,
you know, purple state sort of. Um,
but uh, I did ask myself, you know, um,
am I perpetuating this filter bubble?
Is My feed now going to be filled with
stuff that I already believe and uh,
am I not getting exposure? Should I
be, should I have had more curiosity?
Is like why on earth would people
I know support a candidate who I,
let's just say I can't get behind who
was a walking Cheetos. You can say
the worst. Um, okay, so here's the thing.
I tell people off jump like my social
media platforms are not democracies there.
Dictatorships, I will delete
our block, our report as spam,
as at, at will. Okay.
And feel no guilt about it because
here's the thing is that's not a filter I
really even want to be a part of,
to be like clearing your
space of Trump supporters who,
that was one of the few things that
I draw the line. It's like, oh,
we can't be friends off jump. Okay.
Like there's no conversation here.
You support him because supporting him
means you support and tolerate hate and
misogyny and Islamophobia and
antisemitism and anti woman.
And it's just anti every thing that
is not straight white male and it's a
problem.
So you deleted those people.
I don't think it's necessarily creating
a filter bubble because here's the thing,
what do you learn from them
besides what you already know,
which is that hate does
exist in the world.
And even educated people who are
somewhat sensible and logical can still
tolerate awful things and
people who perpetuate that.
And I don't have the capacity to even
do that. Like I don't, I am not a, um,
mediator. I'm not the person you
walk up to just like, oh my God,
let me see both sides. Oh No. I'm
very much biased about everything.
So yeah.
I've
heard you talk about the difference
between journalism and writing. Yeah.
You consider yourself a writer and it
sort of speaks to this a biased and proud
sort of attitude you have. Can you
talk a little bit, you know, uh, we,
we at Google we have things like Google
news and even our search results,
we work very hard to
make them fair and uh,
talk about journalism versus writing
and not only the role you have in that
spectrum, but where should Google
said it? Should we be opinionated or,
um,
so I do call myself a writer and not
a journalist because I feel like as a
journalist you do have to maintain some
level of like what objectivity and just
be like, you know what, I'm not
always going to choose sides.
I don't know how to do that.
I'm the person who can't write.
I can't write anything but op eds I can
give you, but there'll be fact base.
So for me,
I give myself the responsibility of making
sure I'm double checking to make sure
I'm not passing on fake news,
making sure that my opinion is
based on some fact that I heard.
So that is important. Um, as a company,
I understand if Google wants to
maintain like neutral ground,
so it shows both sides.
But then as a person of opinion,
and I think as a leader in all things,
Google might need to one day step
up and say, actually this is the,
this is the lane that we pick. Like
if somebody goes into Google and, um,
wants to find a way to join a hate group,
I feel like it should be a little bit
more difficult for them to find it,
you know,
to find that type of information
because essentially you can serve up the
information to them on a platter and be
like, just because we're being impartial,
but what does that do for the
world? And how does that impact, um,
what the betterness of the world.
And I think Google is a company
that cares about that in some way.
Sort of make it that easy.
I feel like it would be a mistake.
Yup. The people that aren't working on
youtube or thinking about that, right.
But it is, I mean, you look at Google,
it's pretty clear we have a
very diverse workforce. Um,
just looking out at the
audience. Um, I'm kidding.
He was like,
I'm shit.
I wish this was representative of our
workforce. Unfortunately this is a
virus.
So, um, but we are working
on it. Uh, I think,
you know,
we have,
we're very much in a listening
and learning mode and as
we try to address this,
like any, uh, any advice on that front,
how do we actually create the people
who are creating these products?
How can they more represent
the world and the audiences?
Google and other tech companies
have got to start trying harder,
even harder than you are now.
Because here's the thing is I think,
I feel
like every company needs to reflect the
world as it is for the greater good of
that company too.
Because more diverse voices in the room,
your product is going to be even better
because you're getting all types of,
you would be like, have you thought about
this? That doesn't work. What about this?
And I think it's in your best
interest to get you some more color,
get you some more people of different
backgrounds who can be in a room and be
like, okay, this is what I think.
And then get shut out by
their coworkers who are white.
Um,
you know,
like even recently I was reading an
article about how the women in the White
House and the Obama administration have,
have formed like this bold tron when,
when they're in meetings,
if one woman says an idea,
another woman repeats it and then
somebody else repeats it, who's a woman,
just so the idea is not given to a man.
Cause we'd been enough rooms where we
say something and everyone's like, eh.
And then the dude says it and they
were like, great idea. You like word.
Like I didn't just say that four times.
So in that type of a way,
I think I'm tech companies need to
one, if not even necessarily, um,
them having a conscious bias to be like,
I'm just only going to hire white people.
That's not it.
We tend to engage with people who
are in close proximity with us.
People who look like us,
who are like in our immediate circles.
So those are the people we end up,
uh,
tell him they have job opportunities
and those people end up,
I'm basically applying what needs to
happen is the very pointed and focused
attempt to go outside of that proximity.
Like go to places where you haven't been
asked people who don't look like Doug's
executive team and honestly
get some black void,
your executive team to y'all need
that. Um, but I think it's a,
it's a process that needs to start
now and people need to be very, uh,
very prioritizing the about it.
Like it shouldn't be one of the things
I was like, if it happens, it happens.
It needs to be like a focus. Yeah.
Because in what, 2030 or 2040,
there's going to be no ethic
majority in the, in the country.
So it behooves Google and Facebook
and Twitter and all of them.
Apple, like everybody needs to
start making it a point to fine.
And it's not a quarter system.
It's not you being like,
well we need more black people. We
need for Latinos, for Asians. No,
you want to find people who qualify
and they're out there. Like people say,
I can't find black techies,
I can't find Latino techies.
There are Twitter lists of people who
have 500 best says black techies at the
top.
So we're out here where we exist and be,
we do have some competence in search,
so we ought to be,
oh, okay. Like Google is like the
search Kane of the entire universe.
Okay. Not even an earth. They're
probably aliens is using Google. Um,
so you have no excuse not to be able to
find and find the people who are good.
Yeah.
Cool.
Um,
so you have the spirit of uh,
putting us on the spot. Yeah.
Me In particular, I want to share
something you recently wrote another day,
another Hashtag white people,
you gotta get to work now
about the killings of black
people by law enforcement.
You say white people, I'm talking
to you. This is your problem to fix.
Y'All got some work to do
because the system that y'all
keep on privileging from,
you've got to help us dismantle it because
those of us who are black and Brown,
we have tried, you created this robot
in it is yours to deactivate my skin.
Folk don't have the passcode. This
is your monster to slay word. Yeah.
So,
um,
for those of us that agree,
where do we start?
How do we become better at
helping slay the monster?
Yeah, you got to slay the dragon man. Um,
it's a multistep process and I think it
comes from we can change policy all day
everyday,
but if policy is changed,
but the hearts of the people who are
in these spaces when force it don't,
nothing happens. So the, the,
the real deep belief that it is the
job of white people to fix racism.
Because if we could have fixed it by now,
we would have done it.
And we have tried. So one listening, um,
I've seen enough conversations
where people are like,
here's how I felt when this
issue happened. And somebody
walks in and be like,
well, maybe you're just
looking at it the wrong way.
I was telling you how I thought about it,
but here you are trying to argue me
down about my opinion and my feelings,
which feelings are valid.
So one,
listening to when these things happen, a
lot of times people will say, you know,
I don't know what else to say at this
point is getting even worse if you don't
know what to say. Amplify the
voices of those who do. So you know,
lending your platform to people
who are able to say, you know what,
this is how it's affected me. This is
what I think we need to do. So Linda,
your platforms,
the black and brown voices,
I also think people need to put
their money where their hearts are.
People have money.
Silicone valley has money at the minimum.
Help donate to antiracist organisations
and people who are actively doing the
work to fix it.
People who need the resources and
you will need to get in the room. Um,
that's important.
And then some of us have all these
platforms to speak up, speak up.
Um, use it. Cause here's the
thing, I don't have a job. Okay.
Have them say something. Nobody's going
to be like love you, you're fired.
So it is in my best interest to use my
voice because I don't have anything to
lose there.
Um,
and also one thing that we need to do
because it's like right here it's lowest
common denominator is our friends and
our family members when they say hateful
things about people who are not
in our group who are marginalized,
it is,
we have to say something and you know,
you know what we do when we see some
stupid stuff and Facebook will like scroll
and we'll like scroll past
and roll eyes and be like,
Oh I hate the fact that they just
said that but we never confronted.
So that person thinks it's okay.
So even across the dinner table when
somebody is saying something hateful,
it is in that moment.
You have to let them know
you can't tolerate it because
that means if you let it
happen and you say nothing, you are
saying it is fine, it should happen.
Just like that huffing and puffing
is not enough actively being like,
hey, that's actually not an okay
statement, here's why you're wrong. Um,
and I wrote that piece a lot of actually
got a lot of notes and in the two weeks
afterwards from people who've been like,
I've actually taken that on.
One of my friends emailed me and said,
um,
her husband's father always says
something racist every time.
And he just scrolls past it and shakes
his head and Facebook and he's like, ah.
That irritates me.
After I wrote that piece,
his father puts him like racist joke up
and he sends him a three paragraph email
about how that was not okay.
And she was like,
I just want to say thank you because he
told me to let you know that the reason
he did he did that was
because he read your piece.
And he realized that he can't be quiet
anymore about it. So even small things,
we don't all have to start
a nonprofit organizations.
We don't have to be the ones marching,
but we can do stuff in our everyday lives
that actually can move the needle just
a little bit.
Yeah, I really, that was, that
was some amazing practical advice.
I wasn't actually expecting,
expecting that much actionable stuff that
I think all of us can do in this room,
in this company and in this world.
Um,
I know for me one of the
challenges was sort of, um,
coming to grips with how much
I had to learn. And for me,
a lot of it was really in taking this
unconscious bias training where I sort of
walked in their sleepwalking
walking, like, you know, uh,
not expecting to be rattled
or shaken by what happened.
But what was really revealed was a lot
of the societal conditioning that had
sort of, even me, a good
guy who's trying, you know,
to be part of the solution. There's a lot
of deep work we have to do. Right. Um,
that, you know, it was very
humbling in a lot of ways.
It sort of like the last thing I wanted
to do once that part of me was out there
was sort of um,
get up and pretend to be part of the
solution when I understood I was part of
the problem. Right. And I think the answer
is sort of both. You know, like, um,
when I first started really concentrating
my team on some issues around
diversity and inclusion,
um,
I reached out to a friend of mine who's
been doing this work for really 30 plus
years and she was sort of like,
welcome to the conversation, you know,
it was um, um, people, there
are professionals, you know,
there are people who have spent careers
and lifetimes thinking about these
problems and you know, I know a lot
of us are waking up for the moment,
for the first time,
but it's important to sort of plug in.
And I think your suggestion even didn't
just give resource, whether that's money,
time,
technology platforms to those people
who are professionals and have actually
spent a lifetime thinking
about some of these things.
Is really important for those of
us that are quickly catching up. So
I mean, I think part of
the thing is, you know,
when you start talking about race
and you start talking about like
responsibility of white people,
a lot of times people feel accused like
they're personally the ones who are
being racist. But here's thing that
people have to understand is privilege.
No matter what it is your privilege is,
you know,
like I have a bunch of privileges,
I have class privilege,
I have a sexual orientation privilege,
I have gender identity, privilege, um,
religion, privileged. So I,
there's certain things that I need to
understand that in all of these systems
because I am a part of it and I benefit
from it, I am a part of the problem.
And it's not a loving, you did this one
thing that was wrong to this person. It's,
you are part of the system that even
though you might not have contributed
personally to,
you still have to help fix it because
you're in a position where you can
influence stuff and you can,
I can be in a room where, um,
I am one of the,
um,
I'm going to assume that most people
knew are Christians and that gives me a
safe space to talk about my religion.
But if somebody is there who's
Muslim and they feel like they're,
they're not safe because
they're in this space,
it's my job as somebody who is of
the majority group to make them feel
comfortable and welcome. Like
I can't just be like, well,
it's not my fault cause I don't really,
I ain't say nothing bad
about Muslims today.
So last night I ain't got
nothing to do with me know, like,
so I think it's really important
to use it privileges, um,
to basically help marginalized people.
And also part of what we start learning
about privilege and our space and the
space that we take up in the world,
um,
is that we are lucky one,
we've done nothing to be in
these spaces a lot of times.
Like I was born Christian, I
was, I've never been poor. Um,
so for me it's like, okay, I can't take
credit for that. I can't do like, well,
you know, I earned it. I didn't, I didn't,
it gave me a lot of things
that I worked for him.
But also you have to unlearn
a lot of things like you,
you realize that we've
been programmed so well.
Then in the process of fixing it means
you have to unlearn stuff as in dump that
out your head. That is not
what the world is really about.
And that's the really hard part of
unlearning everything you've known for the
right way for how many years
you've been on this earth.
So you just kinda gotta commit to it.
It's not going to be easy.
It's an ego is a drop kick to your ego
when you realize you're part of the
problem. It is, it's like damn,
I didn't know I was that person.
You are now, now that you
know that you are that person,
how do you not become that person?
How do you make sure somebody else would
not hurt by your personhood? And uh,
once the night she wrote about in my
book was um, has, I want to hear it.
You heard about the privilege exercise.
I feel like every company
in Silicone Valley,
actually every company in general
needs to make this happen.
So the privilege exercise changed my
life and how I looked at the world and I
was a counseling center paraprofessional
when I was in college, trained, um,
to be a peer counselor.
But the whole first semester was us
learning about who we are and the space we
take up.
And literally we spent a whole six months
talking about ourselves and who we are
unpacking them. So one thing we
did with the privilege exercise,
so everyone starts in the same line.
Okay,
you started the same line and they
make a statement, you the step forward,
a step back. So a statement would
be something like step forward.
If you've never had to worry about
somebody in mispronouncing your name,
people step forward, step back if
you've never worried about, if you've,
if you sometimes worried about
where your next meal is coming from,
somebody steps back, you know, step up
if you can marry the person you love.
So it's a series of questions.
Sometimes it's like 20 questions,
sometimes it's 50 at the end of the
privilege exercise they say stop and look
around the room and see where you
are in relation to other people.
So sometimes I found myself for more
higher to the front than I actually
imagined I would be and
some of my classmates in the
back. And I was like, wow,
you're behind me. And it gives you the
perspective of understanding like, okay,
so the privilege exercise, you get
to actually get to figure out, wow,
I'm behind a lot of people.
I never would have thought that or I'm
actually way luckier than I thought I was.
And it teaches you about who the people
you're around are and also some of their
struggles because some of my classmates
who are white girls were behind me.
And I was like, I wonder
why. So we got to unpack it.
I feel like it's really important for
companies to do this cause give your
employees a chance to understand where
they are in the world and what they fit
in. Because sometimes in these
rooms, the people of color,
the people who are different January
to LGBT people might not feel like they
have room to even step up
and say something to you
because they might get shut
down.
And the people who were saying things
never understand that they take up a lot
of room all the time and don't
give them for other people.
So it's a way to kind of recalibrate
and get folks to understand that I might
need to either shut up more,
wanting to step up more,
or I need to like advocate for more
people or I need to be the one that's like
advocating for myself more.
I think it will be good for Google
to do it for a couple of people. Wow,
that's a great exercise.
Yeah.
MMM.
What I want to do.
We've got a couple of mics up here and
we do want to make this interactive.
So as you think of your questions,
while you're doing that,
I want to invite lovey too.
If you're willing and open to it.
Maybe read a section of your book,
do a little reading for us. Yes,
I can do a reading and
I'm trying to figure out,
should I do one for, okay. So my, my book
is, is a broken up into four sections.
Live culture, social media
and fame. Now each section,
so the life is like full of shenanigans.
The culture section I talk about
like racism, homophobia, religion,
social media section. I'm talking about
Hashtag I hate your hashtag abuse.
Uh,
Facebook is my favorite soap opera.
A dumbed down news.
How does succeed in business failure?
Real g's move in silence.
So what section would you
like me to read from? Okay,
Gotcha. All right, let's do it. That
was pretty unanimous. All right.
So I actually just basically
give you a run down in the, uh,
let's see.
I think I'll do religion.
Uh,
yeah,
I have a chapter on rape culture
and here I'd just be, I went in,
uh, I'm trying to see
what I haven't touched on.
Privilege. Racism. Okay. So
yeah,
I wrote my, a piece of my racism
sec chapter while I was, while
it was like a week after the Charleston
shooting and it was that night a church
had been set on fire in
South Carolina and I was, uh,
moved to right cause I
was just like so angry.
MMM.
In Charleston,
South Carolina,
a small Bible study group was praying
to the Lord and otherwise uneventful.
Wednesday at Emanuel Ame Church,
the oldest black church in the south,
a white supremacist walked
in and pretending to want
to pray with them and then
pull the gun out and murdered nine
black worshipers in cold blood.
It an invasion of a place of refuge,
of violation of a little safe space and
definitive proof that there is still a
war on black people in America.
Nowhere is safe for us and the work that
has been done over half a century to
get us closer to equality has regressed.
And it feels like we're back to where
we started and now another one of our
churches is burning and this was 2005
Americans treat and black people like
vermin and it's hard not to feel
like we're unwanted, unsafe.
It's open season on black people in
that was not some lone gunman who walked
into manual Amie.
He represents the ongoing commitment to
keep us in our place of violent reminder
that we are not safe,
we're not safe in the streets,
in our homes at the park or at church,
and I'm fucked up about it because
this was supposed to be history,
not the present.
And I feel the anger from the top of my
head is reverberates down to my toes.
This rage makes my skin burn. I feel the
fire in my bones. This is racist men.
It's worse, it's ugly, demented and vile.
It's also permeates every fiber of what
the United States is made of and it's
what's build the
foundation of this country.
Okay?
It's truly exhausted and I'm not sure
if I'm thankful for the undeniable proof
that racism is still around us or wishful
for the days when we could be tricked
into thinking things were not so bad,
but racism is not just random individuals
burning churches and black people
being gunned down the street is a
system of oppression that is so deep and
omnipresent that it seeps into every
single aspect of our lives and it is as
American as Apple Pie. Drizzle with
canned cheese, top of French fries,
the red stripes on the flag.
I really the blood of black and brown
people in many centuries after the
country's creation,
these stains still have not faded.
And let's pause here to say the
racism in America is a stupid as hell.
Racism and prejudice anywhere is dumber,
but it makes no sense
because it's just absurd.
The United States of America is a
country founded on the labor and literal
bodies of black and brown people who
are minding their own business. Well,
white folks came forth
to kill an exploit them.
This is a place that was discovered by a
dude who didn't know how to read a map.
So he just showed up
on some short thought.
He was in India and then proceeds
a plant a flag and go, Tada.
Know what Christopher Columbus needed
was a compass and a clue for being
aggressively mediocre.
But he has a federal holiday in his honor.
He showed up on someone else's property
and claimed it as his because he didn't
know what it was.
This country started off all the way
wrong and continued in the same fashion.
Okay. I feel like Chris
need a Google maps. Okay,
like you in the wrong place or this is
not India hot mess and we celebrate hill.
We celebrate him. This is
the, this is so American.
And then Chris, lot of native Americans
wiping out a whole, whole tries.
Pillaging the people in called the
Thanksgiving and then to add to the mess,
the Dude Bros realized that he didn't
have the ability to build dope shit on
their own. So they went to African
capture. Black people are them,
brought them here to be their slaves after
killing millions on the journey here.
Because if you want to
out terrible yourself,
you stuck millions of human beings
inside ships, refuse to feed them,
let them lie in their home field
and then let them die in droves.
So not only did you steal someone else's
home and then killed them when they
showed you kindness,
you went elsewhere and then did some
more steel in this time of actual people,
you forced them to come to your stolen
has to do your work for you. I mean,
you're welcome for this too long. Didn't
read version of parallelism in America,
but this is why I should teach.
Okay?
I wouldn't do any worse than current
textbooks like the ones in Texas.
They use the words workers instead
of slaves in the section about the
transatlantic slave trade,
they call them workers as if black people
were at a career fair in Africa where
we submitted resumes and asked to be
beaten and starved and have our families
broken in exchange for a journey
across the ocean with no money.
Like this is not linkedin.
Why we're not workers. Okay.
So my point is that the United States
does not have a legitimate history of
integrity and fairness.
It's been run by villains that
make Disney's look like saints.
Racism is not a byproduct as much as it's
the foundational stock in the American
soup.
And this is why black people are still
fighting to be recognized in our food for
humanity is success of the country
has been based on our oppression.
So of course it is forever fresh out of
dam to give it by black lives and we are
left agree for those. We've lost
the grubby hands of white supremacy.
We rage about the perpetual
cycle of mourning we find
ourselves in and we wonder
what we need to do to be
secure in our own skins.
Wow.
Powerful ideas but also powerful
writing. I was really, thank you.
Okay. Questions from you?
We have to mix up there.
Googlers aren't shy usually, right?
Don't be shy. I have a lot of practice.
We have this event called Tgi F,
which we hold on Thursday. Of course.
Um, and uh, we, we have these mics up
there and people are always asking,
our founders in leadership are
pretty much anything calling,
telling it like it is. It is a
great tradition. So questions.
Thank you.
So first queen,
just want to honor you and thank you
for existing and being here. Jay,
share and help lift us all up.
Also on acknowledge.
I wish this room was completely full
because you deserve all of the 60,000
Googlers listening to you. Um, so there's
that. But actually do have a question.
My question is as Google works on
trying to continue to diversify,
so we actually have people working here
that reflect the people we serve around
the world.
How can we also change the culture so
people are allowing us to be ourselves?
I feel like what you said earlier about
speaking straight, not padding things,
a lot of sugar,
it really resonated with me.
I think one of the things I find hardest
to be here is that I need to put so
much sugar on the front and the backend.
I can't even call it a sticker sandwich.
It's like a cake.
So how can we as a people and as allies
help people understand that it's not the
same lens. You can't bring in all
these different cultures, Africans,
African Americans, Latinos, Filipinos, um,
anyone who's not white and expect us to
act white and a company that is majorily
white.
So communication is cultural.
That's one thing that I think a lot
of people of color struggle with and
companies like this communication is
cultural for me. I'm a very direct person.
If I need to send you an email, I'm
going to be like, Hey, what's up?
So here's what I need from
you. People prefer, hey,
so I hope your day was going well.
I was wondering if you could possibly
do this for me. Who has that time?
Why gotta like layered it with
1500 can I just get to the point?
And then people were like,
well,
you were kind of short and email because
I asked you a question as opposed to
like went through a three
paragraph diatribe about
how you doing girl wandering
or how was your weekend?
Honestly,
people need to understand that
different communications, um,
skills and different ways people talk.
And email is not an
affront to you as a person.
Like if I was to send you a two
paragraph email because I am on the go,
that's not me being short with you.
That's me being on the go.
And I think a lot of black will end up
being the on the go type style and their
coworkers and the bean. Like I felt like
that was very short of you. Honestly,
there needs to be a little bit more
um, people, he's got their feelings.
That's important.
Get out your feelings as a coworker.
Like somebody sends you an email
in the, you're like, you know what?
I felt kind of short. You can ask
him, be like, hey are you okay?
As opposed to like I hear a lot of
passive aggressive stuff happening.
People get out your feelings.
If I sent you a two paragraph,
two sentence email cause I need something,
it doesn't mean I don't want
to know how well you're doing.
It means in that moment it's quick. So I
think Google might want to do some more,
a different communication styles. Oh,
you know the one thing that helps, okay,
so this is website called 16
personalities.com that allows you to do a
personality test and if you
work closely with any team,
have everybody on the team
do this personality test,
it'll break it down and be like,
okay,
so you'll tell you exactly how that
person who sits next to you communicates
their, the person who is always on the
go, they're very direct there. Like it'll,
it'll even break it down to the commander
did the command at the diplomat of the
mediator.
That helps too for you to understand
how your coworkers like to receive
information,
how they pass it on to.
It is not a front to you learn who
you're like working next to and then as
opposed to people having,
it's like temporary and they
put them in sugar cakes.
Who has time? You guys, come on,
let's do my work and send less emails.
That's also important. Stop email
people for everything. Jesus.
I think part of the problem,
we're all commanders.
What happens if one commander is like,
Oh man, I just got commanded too hard.
Okay. Another question.
Uh, so lovey again,
just to mimic a Sarah, uh,
her, some of her comments, uh,
just thank you for coming here and
making time for us. I'm not playing here,
so my name's Howard and I think, um,
I'd be really curious to hear about.
So there's various domains of types of
work that we could be doing right to kind
of fight institutionalized racism and,
um,
kind of address the racial climate in
general in this country. And you know,
so you can send emails, you can protest,
you can strategize about policy change,
you can mentor,
you can kind of just be a,
even just a shoulder for folks to
crying, you know, cry on and mourn.
And so there's all this
diversity, different things
that we could be doing right.
And I think society kind
of, um, conditions us to,
to maybe want to do some things more
than others because maybe some of these
things might be more risky or challenging,
for instance. So, for example,
for many of us maybe protesting and
getting pepper sprayed in the eyes,
it's kind of like, ah, I don't want to do
that. Um, but like maybe if you say like,
I can volunteer at, you know, an
Oakland impact hub. Sure. I'll do that.
That sounds reasonable. Right. Um,
given the problems that we have
given how minimal amount of, uh,
of the workers there are for us,
you know, to address the problems,
what would you say is
like the, the most, the,
the most important,
I guess prioritize domain of type of
work that we really need to focus on in
order to get shit done,
right? Like there's,
there's tiny different things we can
do and I love the approach of like, oh,
just like way your talents and gifts and
whatever. Like you're really good at it.
That's what she's doing,
I think.
I think there's no one thing to do.
It needs to be a mortal layered approach.
Knowing what you're good at and where
you can fit in though makes a difference.
So I already know I'm not going to be
the person on the front line getting
pepper sprayed out.
I'm not about that life.
I give props to the people who
are my job in this movement.
If anything is to tell the stories and
right. I'm just not built for that.
And which means like the people who do
that are actively putting their bodies on
the line and for them it is.
We owe them to make sure they're supported
and the work that they're doing is
not in vain because if their stand on
these front lines getting pepper sprayed,
it better be for a reason and we better
be working to make sure that doesn't
keep happening to them. So it means
if your job is to write policy,
you are the policy person.
Yes.
Make sure that people who are the who
are in Capitol Hill are changing laws.
If your job is to tell stories,
tell these stories and make sure people
are understanding what's happening in
these streets. What's really happening
now with the media is reporting.
If your job is, if you just have so much
money, you don't know what to do with it,
give it to some of these people who
can then turn that money into something
concrete.
So it really comes down to you don't
have to force yourself to do something
that's outside the realm of your interest,
your passion, what you're good at,
whatever that is, you could find a
way that's going to help. So again,
find what it is,
where you fit in that place and
do it and kick ass in that way.
So I already know I'm not built for the
life of being on the front lines little,
okay.
I know I wouldn't even make it.
I am not built for it. So yeah, like
you have to support in whatever way,
you know how as opposed to you being like,
well I have to be the person that that
no you don't. They're amazing people.
Like uh, black youth project 100
which I have to give a shout out too.
If you want to know some organizations
who are doing amazing work,
who are making sure the Chicago Police
Department is actually been held
accountable. There's black youth
project 100 there's dream defenders.
There is Assata's daughters,
so these are people who you
can be giving your money to,
who will show where the money's going.
Yeah.
Okay. Yes, please. Good morning. Thank
you so much for being here today.
When I saw it on the calendar,
you're going to be here.
I got super excited because my book clubs
when talking about your book for the
last month, so thank you
for being here. Yeah.
My question to you is how do you
get over that first step of fear?
I feel like people will have voices,
they want to say something.
But as you alluded to earlier,
maybe you don't want to say it at work,
we're losing your job or changing in
your world and your friends becoming
different, and how do you get over
that, that sense of fear that you have,
that you feel like you should
be saying something you want to,
but you're worried that you're going
to let go of in the process. Um, fears,
one of those things that fear itself will
cripple you from doing whatever it is.
And then when you do it and push past it,
you understand that you were more afraid
of the theme then how it really was.
So here's the thing. There are oftentimes
when I write a piece that I'll be like,
oh my gosh, am I sure I want
to publish this? And I'll
sit on it. I hesitate on it.
But every single time I press publish,
the response I get, lets me know, yes,
you're supposed to do that.
Because here's the thing,
as a person who was thinking about
that thing that you want to talk about,
that scary, you're probably not
the only person thinking about it.
You are probably amongst people who
are also afraid to say the same thing,
but sometimes all it needs is that one
person to cut through to be like, Hey,
I feel like this is wrong,
or I feel like this is,
and then you'll see the people who
buy. Finally somebody said it, okay,
I come back her up now.
I think it just comes down to push it
past and if it's important enough for you,
say it,
you know you can,
you can put it in the sugar cake if
that makes it fine in that meeting,
but making sure that point is made because
a lot of times people do the things
that they don't even realize
a harp harmful or they
don't understand what damage
is doing and they just need to be called
on it to be like, oh, I didn't even know.
Okay, you right. You might have to
be the scape goat. You just be like,
I'm going to say it. I'm going to
say it because this is how I feel.
This is a valid thing to do and I
feel like it would actually push this
conversation forward. She's got to do
it. It's not going to be like less scary.
You don't have to like, ah, I'm scared
shitless, but I'm doing anyway. Okay guys,
I don't think this is a good
idea and even just doing that,
you just have to power through
it. Like it. Thank you. Yeah.
Okay.
I can see we have more questions.
I think this is the way we're going
to do this. I'm unfortunately,
we're out of time and I know that there
are people who need to set up this for
lunch. This is also our
lunch room. Um, so, uh,
we'll take one more
question and she's here.
That's what I was going to say is we're
going to feed her and show her a Google
bike and a little bit of a tour. So, um,
those of you who want to,
I think it's okay with you if a,
we have a little private time with you
by the side of the stage afterwards,
but we'll do one more formal
question and then, uh,
we'll hand this room back over.
So, uh, one more question please.
Hi.
I first wanted to say thank you.
I'm not quite sure what I'm thanking
you for it, but thank you. Um,
and then I'm not sure if I have a
question or a statement that's two quick
things. Um, first you talked
about diversity and Google.
Um, I received a question from a friend
of mine who said, you work at Google.
How did you get that job?
And I was just absolutely amazed
because I said I applied. Um,
and um, I will say that I'm a high
school dropout, never been to college,
never taken any technical courses,
left high school in 11th grade.
But I have enough confidence to
say I'm good, I'm intelligent.
I applied.
But I think it's a statement is that
I think Google needs to give people
permission to apply. I think we need to
do more reaching out to people and say,
Hey, I don't care if you're this, I
don't care if you're that applied.
We can't just wait for people to
come to us. Um, because they'll say,
that's Google. They don't want
me, I'm not good enough. Um,
so any advice that you have for Google
and all the people who are working on
diversity, I think that would
be great because everybody goes,
how did you get a job there?
And I would love for people that feel
that they are confident enough to at least
look at least try because all
you can be told is no. Um,
and the other thing is you were talking
about racism and I have been just
feeling helpless,
um,
and watching all of the protests and
getting excited about the Justice
Department saying, um, we're
going to take this, uh,
shooting of this innocent or
not so innocent black person.
And then it turns out that the
Justice Department doesn't, you know,
the case doesn't go through. They're
not charged. And I'm a ranter,
which I'm doing now instead
of asking a question. Um,
but I had been posting on Facebook
about the fact that people sit on the
courthouse steps and say,
this is not gonna work.
We have to do something about it.
And we see Beyonce and we
see snoop Dogg and we see,
I'll sharpen all of these activists
and they're saying, this is not good.
We have to stop this.
But then they step back and then they
go back to their everyday lives because
they have this feeling of helplessness
and they don't know what to do next.
So a couple of weeks ago,
I gathered a bunch of friends that I work
with from a design company and we did
this great big, um, like ideation,
brainstorm on what we could
do because in my eyes,
it has to start within the police
department, right? It can't be the police,
it can't be the lawyers that
can't be the district attorneys.
It has to be the police department to Pat,
you know,
to go pass that Blue Line of silence
and start telling the other police
officers, you know what? I'm not going
to testify on your behalf. You are wrong.
You shouldn't have done that. And I feel
like it has to start with from within,
but I don't know what to do next.
We've got a bunch of ideations.
We talked about
redesigning the s, the, um,
pullover and all of these things,
but we're now trying to figure out how
to reach other people and how to use our
voices and making this great big movement
that says it has to start from within
the police department. Right. I
watched this up an episode of, um,
God, I can't remember the
show. Tay Diggs is in it. Um,
I can't remember the name of it,
but he shot a black guy.
They couldn't find the gun,
but his partner told him
the next day, you know what?
I talked to the captain and I
backed you up. And it wasn't true.
And that was just an example of what
happens instead of them saying, no,
he was wrong and I'm not
going to stand by him.
So we're trying to figure out ways to
do that in any advice so that I can take
it to the next step where it's not just
a meeting of people who go back to their
normal lives and say, oh, we met
but I don't know what to do next.
Um,
the first question of how,
so there's is something that feels very
inaccessible about working at Google.
It feels like aspiration as
opposed to a reachable thing.
So a lot of people don't even know it's
an option for them because they use
think people who work at Google happened
to get it like a magic golden ticket
and they showed up. They, they're
like, oh my god, work at Google.
It sounds like a legend. Like, Oh man,
it's like Charlie Wonka's
chocolate factory. Cause I
mean this place is a mess.
What gas slides?
Um,
I think Google needs to do a better job
of making sure that people understand
that they actually have a
chance to work at Google.
And they're not just
like engineers who are,
who get coding things and they're
like, oh, you can be a coder.
You actually have people
do social things at Google.
I think Google needs to actually make
it more accessible so whether you have
people go into more
colleges who were like, Yo,
you don't have to be a hyper
geek engineer to work at Google.
You can actually apply for like the
events coordinator job or the admin
assistant in job or if you are in stem
you can apply for a job in strategy in
coding,
so I'm not sure why what you guys are
doing but you might want to do that.
I know y'all don't throw a post on indeed
or linkedin but that might help but it
actually would help if people knew that
they could get a job at Google and it
wasn't some like pie in the
sky thing mission to apply.
We are doing a lot of that. I want
to just give a shout out to the team.
I actually met with them yesterday and
we have a lot of work to do but there are
people at Google. Part of
it is just making sure we
are aware, people are right,
like mountain view is a little bit
like Disneyland in a lot of ways.
And you know, we have a great big
world out there and Google, uh,
is fortunate enough to have offices in
a lot of places and we have to do a lot
more outreach, a lot more
inviting, a lot more welcoming.
And I know that there are teams of
people at Google working on that. So,
and I also have to like give Google
props because here's the thing,
like I know you're constantly being
told to do better because you should,
but the fact that your leadership
is taking it on as an actual thing,
not just because you are getting
your week's gnashed about it matters.
I think it's really good to see people
at the top who are saying like, okay,
help us figure out what to do.
We realized we need to do better
so we are we going to do better?
So I have to say props for that because
the trickle effect is real, right?
Because the leadership didn't care.
Nothing's going to change.
So I just want to say perhaps
you you for that. Yeah.
Red. Okay. On that note,
did he just blocks?
So no,
behalf of everyone here and Google.
Thank you.
Not only for coming and visiting us,
but the work you do everyday,
putting yourself out there, it makes a
difference. Whom we're very grateful.
Thank you.
Okay.